many people in the United States and
Latin America have grown up celebrating
the anniversary of Christopher
Columbus's voyage but was he an intrepid
explorer who brought two worlds together
or a ruthless exploiter who brought
colonialism and slavery and did he even
discover America at all it's time to put
Columbus on the stand in history versus
Christopher Columbus order order in the
court
wait am I even supposed to be at work
today mm yes your honor
from 1792 Columbus Day was celebrated in
many parts of the United States on
October 12th the actual anniversary date
but although it was declared an official
holiday in 1934 individual states aren't
required to observe it only 23 states
closed public services and more states
are moving away from it completely ah
huh what a pity in the 70s we even moved
it to the second Monday in October so
people could get a nice three-day
weekend but I guess you folks just hate
celebrations uh what are we celebrating
again
come on Your Honor we all learned it in
school Christopher Columbus convinced
the king of Spain to send him on a
mission to find a better trade route to
India not by going east overland but
sailing west around the globe everyone
said it was crazy because they still
thought the world was flat but he knew
better and when in 1492 he sailed the
ocean blue he found something better
than India a whole new continent what
rubbish
first of all educated people knew the
world was round since Aristotle secondly
Columbus didn't discover anything there
were already people living here for
millennia and he wasn't even the first
European to visit the Norse had settled
Newfoundland almost 500 years before you
don't say so how come we're not all
wearing those cow helmets actually they
didn't really wear those either um who
cares what some Vikings did way back
when those settlements didn't last but
Columbus's did and the news he brought
back to Europe spread far and wide
inspiring all the explorers and
settlers who came after without him none
of us would be here today and because of
him millions of Native Americans aren't
here today do you know what Columbus did
in the colonies he founded he took the
very first natives he met prisoner and
wrote in his journal about how easily he
could conquer and enslave all of them oh
come on
everyone was fighting each other back
then didn't the natives even tell
Columbus about other tribes raiding and
taking captives
yes but tribal warfare was sporadic and
limited it certainly didn't wipe out 90%
of the population hmm why celebrating
this Columbus so important to you anyway
your honor
Columbus's voyage was an inspiration to
struggling people all across Europe
symbolizing freedom and new beginnings
and his discovery gave our grandparents
and great-grandparents the chance to
come here and build better lives for
their children don't we deserve a hero
to remind everyone that our country was
built on the struggles of immigrants and
what about the struggles of Native
Americans who were nearly wiped out and
forced into reservations and whose
descendants still suffer from poverty
and discrimination how can you make a
hero out of a man who caused so much
suffering that's history you can't judge
a guy in the 15th century by modern
standards people back then even thought
spreading Christianity and civilization
across the world was a moral duty
actually he was pretty bad even by old
standards while governing Hispaniola he
tortured and mutilated natives who
didn't bring him enough gold and sold
girls as young as nine into sexual
slavery and he was brutal even to the
other colonists he ruled to the point
that he was removed from power and
thrown in jail when the missionary
Bartolome de las Casas visited the
island he wrote from 1494 to 1508 over 3
million people had perished from war
slavery and the mines who in future
generations will believe this well I'm
not sure I believe those numbers say
aren't there other ways the holiday is
celebrated in some Latin American
countries they celebrate the same day
under different names such as dia de la
raza in these places it's more a
celebration of the native and mixed
cultures that survived through the
colonial period some places in the US
have also renamed the holiday as Native
American Day or indigenous peoples day
and changed the celebrations accordingly
so why not just change a name if it's
such a problem because it's tradition
ordinary people need their heroes and
their founding myths can't we just keep
celebrating the way we've been doing for
a century without having to delve into
all this serious research it's not like
anyone is actually celebrating genocide
traditions change and the way we choose
to keep them alive says a lot about our
values well it looks like giving tired
judges a day off isn't one of those
values anyway
traditions and holidays are important to
all cultures but a hero in one era may
become a villain in the next as our
historical knowledge expands and our
values evolve and deciding what these
traditions should mean today is a major
part of putting history on trial